so much has happened since I saw you  lost Miami like yesterday so that's  still pretty fresh then I went on the  journey of self-discovery I love you  [Music]  where are we you have no idea  hello the goddess of death is invaded as  god oh I miss this  and you and I how to fly-fish me  now I want easily since I'm right Oh  [Music]  oh god is dead little be reborn in my  image I thought you'd be glad to see me  need a stopper here now prevent riding  the rock the end of everything  so I'm putting together a team  at the old days  surprised did we stop  hi  are you a fighter  here we go  I'm not a queen or a monster  the goddess of death  what were you the god of again  [Music]  by the same you like to come huntin  fools  yes same all kite choir boy like water  and birth like higher the whole like  raging fire - I like smoldering fire  you  you